من السماء ومنصات العالم الافتراضي وشبكات
الاتصال ومحاولات الاختراق وحتى من خلال
الاشخاص قضايا تجسس كثيره كشف عنها النقاب
في الولايات المتحده واشارت اصابع الاتهام
الامريكيه فيها الى اقصى الشرق الى الصين
فشركه هواوي الصينيه المشغله لشبكه الجيل
الخامس واجهت عقوبات في الولايات المتحده
في عهد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بذريعه
مخاطر عملها على الامن القومي الامريكي
وهو الاتهام نفسه الذي وجهته اداره ترامب
لتطبيق تيك توك رغم اعلان الشركه المالكه
له انه منصه عالميه لا منتج صيني القضاء
الامريكي حافل ايضا بقضايا صدرت في بعضها
احكام باداره اشخاص قيل انهم تجسسوا لصالح
الصين ومنهم موظفون سابقون في شركات كبرى
جنرال الكتريك باور وشركاتنا امريكيه
عابره للحدود ومتخصصه في مجالات الطيران
والفضاء والادويه وغيرها لكن ما الذي
تريده الصين وفق ما تتهم به من الولايات
المتحده ودول اخرى استنادا لوحده
التحليلات الاستخباراتيه التابعه لمجموعه
من خلال سرقه الاسرار والمعلومات الى
الصعود السريع لدرجات سلم التقدم
التكنولوجي والصناعي بتكلفه اقل وهذا يعني
بالضروره تقويه الاقتصاد وزياده النفوذ
والتاثير للوصول الى مرحله الهيمنه على
القطاع الصناعي على مستوى العالم باسره في
الولايات المتحده منذ عام 2019 تقرير لجنه
استشاريه بشان العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
لمراجعه الامن والاقتصاد في الكونجرس الى
ما وصفه باتساع وتعقيد نشاط الصين التجسس
في الولايات المتحده كما جرى الحديث في
الجلسه نفسها عن تقرير لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ذكر وقتها ان الفانتاغون كشف
الاف المحاولات لدخول غير قانوني على
اجهزه الالكترونيه عام 2008
ان اكثر الهجمات مصدرها الصين التي تصف
هذه الاتهامات بانها استحضار للحرب
البارده وتنفيها بالمطلق